hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario maker today I
am wearing the cat version of the new
shirt duo due off that I said I was
gonna come up with a prize for one to
win but I didn't do that just yet so the
cat version is also available it looks
like this you guys didn't come for that
you guys came for me failing at Mario
maker anyway in the last one I was voted
hey I should probably have that that's
probably okay wait how do I oh god feel
so good oh how do I wait oh that's right
jump and then do man I don't know all
the rules to the new Super Mario because
I actually have anything Oh God
oh no no okay
it's a lot of trickery oh god dammit I
just got to not suck it's very hard
considering exactly who I am
oh yes I'm amazing oh look at me oh I'm
the best crack-a-lackin' okay so what I
was saying the other day about improv
and all that jazz is that uh it's always
been a passion of mine to be better at
comedy because comedy is like the heart
of everything I do on let's and on
sketch comedies as well so if I'm not
good at the very basic elements of what
I do then I've got a bit of a problem
like I I need to be more disciplined on
what I do because there's always like
there's always like people people would
say like oh you're pretty funny or
something like that oh you make me laugh
all the time but it's always like I've
never been trained and and people are
inherently funny or not but there's also
rules that can make it a more fun time
and that's where like learning about
improv comes into play because like
Danny naturally exceptionally funny dude
I love watching game grumps if I haven't
mentioned game grumps enough like
they're my favorite channel in YouTube
I'm very lucky to be able to hang out
with them like on a regular basis and
work with them together and be able to
see them and I still to this day every
single day I watch the game grumps it's
my favorite channel know no question
about anything
it's always going to be
my favorite Channel I love it to death
yay I did something I don't know what
though it's always going to be my
favorite Channel and in addition to that
so if I just drop this here yes oh god
damn it it's always gonna be my favorite
Channel so being able to do that on a
daily basis is amazing and come on come
on
any-any what what are you what are you
buddy what are you what are you doing
can you can you just can you why did
this work perfectly the first time it's
not gonna work now just just oh my god
just go oh my god come on just why are
you not doing this oh come on just okay
just okay
just yes
come on just little little little come
on just I what I'm trying it I'm holding
okay that was cut down no it's not oh my
god just Jimmy oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh you guys don't it may not you may
not okay just okay you guys you may have
covered this before I don't handle
frustrating things very well when things
are frustrating it's like nails on a
chalkboard times a million when things
don't do do you
no legged nod with it as I was saying
I'm the very lucky car to be able to
hang out with you know such talented
people as such our the game grumps as
such do as such they are the game grumps
that I I love them to death and I love
being able to work with them on a
regular basis and what I'm saying is
that Danny naturally very funny guy and
love him to death because he's super
super super cool but at the same time
damn it but at the same time I want to
be able to you know have like sharp wit
like that which is like very important
to me because sharp wit is the
quintessential thing of everything on
YouTube and improvisation and all that
Jetts damn it that's gonna be hard as
shite how am I gonna be able to get
there in time that doesn't make any
goddamn sense to me it's and and what's
interesting like the dynamic between say
game grumps and say what I do is that
they always have two people so that when
one person is like playing this
embracing at it the other can be telling
the story that's important and what
everyone wants to hear how about running
out of goddamn time come on how do i how
can I just I'm gonna just drop that's
stupid
Oh goddamn it how am I gonna be able to
do that why am I just floating like a
loser
god dammit Mario stop swinging your arms
like an Indian just go up okay how do I
do this
god dammit okay maybe just run sprint oh
I know
nope god damn it
ah that was it okay I just got to do
straight up on the do daddy yeah okay I
can do this I'm running out of time okay
just run straight there come on come on
come on come on oh [ __ ] me in the
pothole Oh God I can do this huh Oh
because when there's another person
there then they can probably provide
more intelligent commentary than just
went higher than the other one did in
that time it did when it goes higher
it's like not enough time so anyway as I
was saying when it's two people playing
as such as the game grumps they can talk
to each other and they can take turns
expressing their eternal rage whereas me
I'm by myself so a lot of this have to
do with just me myself and I and that
doesn't mean that I don't play games
with friends on occasion I do do that
and it's good it's good times when that
happens
but alas it's not always the case and
the last moratoria of the time and by
myself just me myself and an endless
ocean of eternal rage building within my
very soul I'm probably not even halfway
through the level I was probably
supposed to take way less time than this
oh gosh
no no no no you will die oh come on that
was right on the thing I'm already
breaking a sweat guys I'm already
breaking a sweat but in a lot of ways
like whereas you know the game grows
they talk to each other I have the very
good pleasure of talking to you guys
even though you aren't here present at
the very moment but in my mind you guys
being there and in the commets is like
my version of what they get to enjoy
with each other but whereas I'm talking
I'm not talking to myself because
talking to myself would just be the
tiniest bit bonkers for what I'm trying
to do and I hope this doesn't give me
trouble again nope no come on oh come on
no just just jump on just yes there we
go okay no problem here we go rip on
down down down okay this one this one
this one this one good oh god that
doesn't look fun oh no oh no no no don't
do that
oh no oh how is that supposed to be done
oh that's a bunch of [ __ ] oh my god
I could die here oh good okay if they if
they made me die here how am I gonna be
able to do that I guess I got to go
under it cuz that would make more sense
yeah okay
can't hit it at all it's got to be a way
to go under it that would get me to
where I need to go I'm also on a time
crunch Oh
Oh God why is there more of this well
that doesn't make any sense why is that
up there
Oh God oh I know what you oh I don't I
have no I have no goddamn idea I I
honestly have no idea what you wanted me
to do there but I know what you want me
to do that's not good
damn it okay hang on I know how to do
this I think anyway I think maybe man I
can't believe I ran completely out of
time in the last one this is kind of
depressing for what I'm doing it Lodi
floaty floaty
oh god damn it
oh [ __ ] a look oh okay all right
everything's fine everybody everything's
fine see that's what I mean when the
dynamic is between you and me guys
because you guys can't see you but
you're all I have
it's not like a thing of where oh oh
it's not like a thing of where oh I wit
ha god damn it [ __ ] me in the battle no
don't die god oh if I have died oh
that's gone all the way back to the lady
I don't wanna do that
oh man I can't believe this one had like
a 5.6 completion rate some people would
have just given up after a while I mean
I appreciate it it's very well made
stuff weak stop being dick stop being
ass dick stop being butthole dick hole
huh
anyway the basics of improvisation is
trying to be at the top of your
intelligence adults [ __ ] you oh I did
not know I could see I didn't I don't
play the Newmar I didn't know I could
dive bomb down that would have been very
helpful in the other ones god damn it
okay so you're all I have and what I
mean that I mean that with a sense of
desperation
you're literally all I have the only
link to sanitized
you guys and if you guys weren't here
then I wouldn't know what to do not not
in that I wouldn't know what to do but I
wouldn't know what to do with my life
because I'm at a very fragile point in
my site kosis I hate Springs
I hate Springs I hate Springs and
everyone knows why I hate Springs
because someone unleashed nope go yes
god damn oh man I'm getting angry I'm
getting angry
see it's it's not Ross it's it's not
Ross think I hate more than names these
things not doing them when I swear to
God [ __ ] you how many times am I gonna
fail at this before I just
okay that's the game that we're gonna
play over here you're just gonna slide
me up the [ __ ] side of face with your
[ __ ] and then take everything I ever
loved away from me oh I'm just a so I'm
not gonna take everything everealm I
don't even know your it's very
impersonal bro shut up shut the [ __ ] up
hey don't give a frame
oh I've never been so angry in my life
I've never been so angry I've never ever
ever been so angry in my life oh I've
never been so angry in my goddamn life
so these shirts are on sale cats and
dogs shirts look fine
I'm fine to worry about me some people
are probably like I'm red before ever I
read the comments you know Oh mark scary
when he's angry yeah yeah okay I don't
you know this is only the second video I
plan to record today earth there's only
the second video I recorded a I plan to
do a bunch
I just royally destroyed my throat
screaming totally involuntary I do not
handle rage well so thank you everybody
so much for watching
write me something nice in the comments
below and I'll read it and hopefully
it'll make my day just a little bit
better
so remember cat versus dog shirts
available in the description thanks
again everybody for watching
as always I will see you
as an assist in some way or another to
some way knowing that they helped